dude christian i got to know about your
book it's been there this whole show and
i've been looking at it is it i don't
want to derail anything yeah we have
like books yeah tell me about this
virtue so it's called virtue bombs what
and you you lived in la is that's what
this is about the internet i mean i just
cover it i cover hollywood what's going
on
it's exactly what we talk about as far
as narratives but it's a woke narrative
that's just crushing hollywood it is
making things less creative it's
obviously you know attacking comedy it's
uh identity politics gone wild it's so
many things that are going
wrong with hollywood and one of the
things that i really upset about the
whole situation is i'm waiting for that
tom hanks that denzel that meryl streep
to come out and and take a stand against
what's happening in the industry and
they won't do it they're all scared to
death why is it what do you think it is
i miss fear you know i i i talk about
this in the book very early on hollywood
is all about fear it's like fear of
getting older fear of losing the next
gig fear of your movie not making any
money if you have someone behind you
who's better looking and more talented
going to take your role you know fear of
you know
getting young you know getting old
cancelled cancel well now then you add
this layer to it and it's a whole new
layer and they're scared they're just
absolutely terrified that's why no one
very few people are saying i mean adam
carollo's the ricky gervais's the joe
rogans they are standing up they're
doing something about it but they're the
exception to the rule
you think like tom hanks is afraid he
might get canceled tom hanks just
decided to uh narrate a special about
joe biden's first year
you know why
not just that he's a liberal and that's
fine with him
his movies aren't doing well right now
he's in his 60s he's looking at things
something i maybe i should kind of you
know secure my situation nick cersei
often says that sometimes actors when
they get really woke on social media
it's not about what they believe or
think they're actually auditioning for
the next role they want to kind of say
hey
i'm with you i'm in the group
this is what i believe well come come
hire me there's like a queue it's called
the q rating or something is that what
it's called uh this sort of approval
rating so what people think of you or
something
in like hollywood i thought the agencies
have like a number they assigned to like
celebrities i haven't you know
definitely true i haven't heard in a
while but that's yeah sort of the
popularity the acceptance things like
that i would say john cena has the best
social credit score especially when it
comes to hollywood and then behind him
is the rock that also shills for the
governor of california yeah this is this
is legit it's called the q score uh
wikipedia says the measurement of
familiarity and appeal of a brand
celebrity or company so tom hanks does
this video because he knows it's going
to get attention sure and then the
agencies are going to be like people
know tom hanks oh yeah no i understand
the whole mechanics behind it i'm just
thinking if you're tom hanks you just
watch the last year of this presidency
even if you voted for biden even if
you're a left of center even if you're a
hardcore democrat you really want to
sign on to this guy at this point what
we just watched i mean that's that kind
of boggles the mind but you see that a
lot did he get paid
who knows who knows i'm sure
the white house admittedly bought social
media influencers on tick tock to
promote the vaccine in their vaccine
effort you know it's hard for me to
think to even comprehend that people
like meryl streep denzel washington are
afraid of getting canceled because
they're so powerful well look at scroll
of johansen it's a big part of my book
is
she's very beautiful she's very talented
she's bankable when when her movies come
out they make money so she's maybe the
most powerful actress in hollywood she
took a role to playing a trans person in
a movie called rub and tug and then the
voke mob came after her
like that i am sorry i'm going to be an
ally i am so i will do better next time
that's the most powerful person in
hollywood what about other people you
know lower lower lower levels the gaffer
on the on the movie set uh an actress
coming up
what do they they think when they see
something like that happen it sends a
signal it's like with dave chappelle the
most powerful comedian of our age the
goat
and yet he's under constant attack now
because he told a few jokes that people
weren't in that some people didn't like
and he starts to falter his last special
was very much him like constantly
addressing the question oh yeah i'm sure
as we mentioned of less than two percent
it's about one percent of the us
population who are active so you have
two percent of the us population active
on twitter about 1.2 or so are are left
because they're slightly more left than
right and dave chappelle is addressing
those people yeah absolutely and also
what's interesting about him is that
what is the message for the other
comedians do you think they're going to
go near that material they're going to
think they're going to take a chance
if they could almost take down dave
chappelle and good for netflix for
standing by him and they've done that
mostly a pretty good job of saying we're
not we we back him we understand what's
going on but if you're like a club comic
and you're just starting out and you
want to kind of engage in some really
challenging topics and themes but you
don't have his skill set and you don't
have his fame i would avoid it
you might not get work i talk to
comedians all the time who get attacked
by other comedians and who try to get
them cancelled it's fascinating but the
system broke
ryan long is enjoying tremendous success
and growing rapidly because he doesn't
care yeah he's funny guy yep he's
existing in this whole new you know he's
not on saturday live he's not any he's
not going to be on netflix but he's got
his own little niche and he's very
successful he's also very good yeah and
he's aggressively political which is
interesting i think about like how
figureheads are so powerful for morale
like if an army of ten thousand men is
is engaging another army with eight
thousand men but then the leader gets
killed the army will rout they'll turn
and run because they've lost command and
if like you see tom hanks bend the knee
then that kind of it's a similar morale
shattering effect on the people that
follow and obsess over tom hanks yeah
oh what were we going to say
when you were writing this did you
follow like the history of this coming
up in the last seven years or something
you know it kind of encompasses that
time period it feels new
ish there have been there have been
echoes of it for a while but it's the
last three or four years where it's
metastasized in a way that is so
powerful and so i mean barry rice's
substract page had an amazing article
recently they had two two investigative
reporters dig into people
i think they interviewed like 25 people
most were off the record because they're
scared to death and they talked about
how if you're a white male in hollywood
you're out you don't get work they they
actively don't want to hire you and it's
listen hollywood has done a terrible job
with diversity and this is a course
correction but it's an extreme course
correction it's way too far
so if you if you're a white comic you're
in trouble you're not going to get the
gigs you're hollywood
it got shattered by internet video i was
there in 2005 6 7 making i started
making youtube videos in 06 and i
watched like the entertainment industry
start to be like what are we going to do
i would get called into auditions and
then they would google my name for the
first time in history an actor they
would look outside of the audition for
who is this guy and they'd see like
crazy videos of me and then they'd be
like i'm not touching that yeah but then
you see maker studios a bunch of
youtubers make this company sells to
disney for a billion dollars because
they're desperate for content and for
entertainment and and it's instead of
people going into hollywood and getting
contracted with paramount they're
starting up their own thing now but for
for a lot of uh you know actors are
marketing essentially they'll put the
name on the title they want to you know
people will go see it because they can
pull you know those actors are
recognizable
with internet video there's a lot of
people and the internet really changed
this there are people who have no
business in certain industries becoming
successful in certain industries by
simple virtue of being famous you know
like the paul brothers or boxers now you
know what i mean like well they're
famous they can get draw they can make
money who cares if they're good at
boxing we're going to make millions of
dollars if we do a boxing match with
them rap battles all of that stuff so
it's the the whole landscape is shifting
and it's turning into are you famous are
you not famous
one interesting thing i noted there's a
new lord of the rings series coming to
amazon prime
465 million dollars poured into just one
season september 2nd is coming so i
don't know a lot about it they haven't
released a lot about it but they had a a
list of the actors who were in it i
didn't recognize a single name yeah the
brand is lord of the rings you don't
need that with even with all that money
they went with a whole bunch of lesser
known actors because that is the
property that's the drawing that makes a
lot of sense
yeah yeah yeah same with the marvel
movies they they i remember if you look
back at the old articles it was really
funny they were sharing them on reddit
and it was like marvel bets big on no
names you know was it chris hemsworth
and tom hiddleston and it was like
showing pictures of them and it was like
can these movies survive and now they're
huge
now they're so famous so they knew and
and marvel notoriously pays very very
little for their for their actors in
these movies they get paid like a couple
hundred grand for except for robert
downey jr he was getting an obvious
scene
i think was it what was it what did they
report like tens of millions of dollars
i mean at that point he was the anchor
the whole the whole franchise so they
just threw they threw the brinks truck
at him so that's right and
so yeah
so it's great but you know what now um
like a lot of uh it's moving to
streaming and it feels like
one thing that really bothers me with
netflix is that they'll do two seasons
of a show no matter what and then just
cancel it it's just really like
spaghetti thread on the wall in a lot of
ways it's also there's no transparency
that netflix will say okay this show is
our number one show and this is number
two but you know with movie theaters you
can see the grossest you can see what
movies make each week a lot of these new
platforms have nothing it's just you
have to trust them you know so we don't
know if it's low ratings or it's too
expensive or there's some sort of
behind-the-scenes controversy we have no
idea you know what it is it's boring
groundhog day was a great movie yeah
sure ghostbusters is a great movie oh my
gosh but no one wants to take chances
anymore yeah and i think it was uh uh
who was it was it um
who was the guy who said
no one wants to take chance anymore
because you'll get canceled and they
thought he was saying you'll get
attacked for being racist what he was
actually saying is they'll cancel your
tv show
i can't remember who that was um
donald glover maybe maybe i don't know
there was he was just like nobody wants
to take take chances anymore because
he'll get cancelled and then everyone
was like just don't be racist what's the
problem he's like no i mean your show
won't make it
like you've gotta stick to the formula
so every movie is becoming very much the
same they're like let's make 12 avatar
movies because that made money let's
make 50 marvel movies that makes money
in your research do you find actors that
buck the system and still keep working
very few very few uh some comedians are
able to do that adam corolla maybe is
one of the best examples you know but he
built his own pirate ship that's what he
calls it it's his own company so go try
to cancel them although one thing i will
say about adam is that no one's even
trying anymore when you punch the bully
back in the nose they kind of go away
but if you kind of let them influence
you then often you'll they'll they'll
kind of own you you know
tina fey is a great example very funny
lady did a lot of great shows and a few
years ago she was under some sort of
quick kind of early cancel culture
attack and she said you know what i make
it a policy not to explain my jokes
which was a great answer that's a good
policy like a year or so ago she's all
woke she's all into cancelled culture
i'm so glad i'm being educated
she just she was
basically just saying the party line
that so three years ago four years ago
she was proud and independent and now
she's been uh re-educated
oh god i'm glad the struggle session
worked and we can all go back and delete
30 rocks what's she why what's she doing
now other than yeah isn't she deleting
episodes of 30 rock you know she had i
think there's a new show that might be
on peacock or something that she might
be involved with but just i was reading
her interviews and she was talking about
comedy and the and the in the atmosphere
and things like that she was completely
transformed but it's like jimmy jimmy
fallon too he was not a great show
margaret show is not funny anymore at
all i don't think she ever was
but i think she was more of a true
believer even i think early on
interesting thanks for checking out this
segment from the tim cast irl podcast if
you want to watch live you can check out
this channel monday through friday at 8
00 pm and don't forget to smash that
like button subscribe to this channel
and if you want more unfiltered and
uncensored content with all of these
guests go to timcast.com and become a
member all of these guests you know and
love in exclusive segments on our
website where we are unrestricted in
what we talk about so you'll definitely
not want to miss it thanks for hanging
out we'll see you all next time
you